yorichi tsugikuni is the strongest Demon
Slayer in history the man who almost
defeated muzon muzon barely escaped
being killed by orichi and then he spent
the rest of yorichi's Life hiding from
him yurichi lived a long life and he
eventually died in his 80s but muzan is
an immortal demon so he had all the Time
in the World to wait it out until
yorichi died yorichi would never be
tempted to become a demon he was just
too pure and virtuous of a warrior to
give up his Humanity for immortality but
what if he became a demon for the sole
purpose of hunting down muzan what if
yorichi tricked his brother into turning
him into a demon and then used his new
demon powers to hunt down and kill muza
could he resist muzon's control like
Tamayo did and then and muzon once and
for all should I make a whole video on
this scenario subscribe to anime uproar
and let me know what you think down in
the comments